[MUSIC PLAYING]
GREG BRAIL: OK.
Good afternoon.
Thanks for coming.
My name is Greg Brail.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
I've been part of the team
that works on the Apigee API
management platform for about
12 years, been at Google
a little more than two years.
I'll be joined later by Keith
Danekind who works in our field
and that's going to
help me with some demos.
And the main thing
we're going to talk
about today is we're
going to talk about APIs.
We're going to talk about
things that companies
have done with APIs.
We're going to show
some examples of that.
We're going to talk about the
business for about 10 minutes.
Then we're going to
get into a little bit
about what API management
technology looks like
and what people are
able to do with it.
So there's our agenda but better
than look at the agenda slide
that's just get started.
So these are
examples of companies
who have had real business
results by using APIs,
either by creating API programs
that are used by third parties,
by creating new digital
experiences with APIs,
or by essentially taking
advantage of the ability
to use an API as a layer on
top of legacy technology.
For instance, Starbucks
has a mobile app
that people use
for buying coffee.
And they also have some
interesting digital wallet
capabilities.
That app runs on an API
that is layered on top
of Starbucks legacy technology.
I'll get better as this goes on.
Similarly, a company
called Arity is actually
in the business to
business business.
And what they've
been able to use
is by having an API
program, rather than
the old fashioned way of
getting partners signed up that
takes months and months to
have conversations, and emails,
and PowerPoints, and things.
By having a self-service
API, their partners
can get on board in just a
few days or even a few hours.
This is an example
of some of the ways
that customers have
been taking advantage
of this API technology that
we all know from the internet.
Applying it to their businesses
and getting some real results.
APIs and API management has
been around for a while.
We've been talking about
it for a long time.
The term API of course,
is 40 years old.
I'm really talking
here about a web APIs.
The kind of APIs that
run on the internet.
The kind of APIs you use when
you interface with Google Cloud
or with third party services
like Twitter, or even Facebook.
Most companies that
start out with API
kind of start out on
the lower left here.
They need to solve some
integration problems.
I need to connect a
new technology platform
to an old technology platform.
I want to make it easy to build
something like a mobile app.
And sort of on the two boxes
on the lower left hand corner,
this is what people were
doing six or seven years ago.
They were doing things like
putting an API layer in front
of a legacy app so that mobile
developers could use technology
they understood
like JSON and HTTP
to build a new experience
for their existing legacy
technology.
But what started to
happen is for one, just
having a mobile
app wasn't enough.
Now we have things
like connected devices,
and smart speakers,
and connected cars,
and talking refrigerators,
and things like that.
And all of those kinds of
things require some sort of API
behind them.
When you say, OK, Google buying
me tickets for the Lady Gaga
concert, that's only
possible if the company that
selling those tickets
actually has some sort of API
for Google Home to speak to.
So fancy marketing
term but instead
of talking about
building apps, now we
talk about creating
digital experiences.
But the companies that have
really done interesting things
with APIs have used APIs to
create new business models
and create marketplaces
and platforms.
And I'll talk about
some examples.
One great example
we have is a Magalu,
formerly known as
Magazine Luiza.
It's the largest
retailer in Brazil.
They'll be speaking
later at the conference.
We'll put up a list of some
of the sessions later on.
Magalu is a brick
and mortar retailer
with stores all over Brazil.
And a couple of
years ago, they began
transforming their
business by changing
from a traditional
retailer to one
that has very strong
capabilities around the web
and around mobile apps.
But in recent years
they've gone even farther.
Now they have a platform.
So third party sellers,
logistics providers,
all kinds of people can both
put products in their stores.
Take advantage of
their network of stores
and their distribution
capabilities
to sell their products.
As well as build other
ways to integrate
with their infrastructure.
Essentially, this
makes Magalu the Amazon
of Brazil, which is funny
because Brazil already
has an Amazon.
But it's something that's
actually given them
huge business
results and actually
huge results in their
stock price as well.
Another great example is
Accuweather, also speaking here
at the conference.
We all know Accuweather
in the United States
as being the person who the
weather man on television
gets information from.
But that weather
person on television
is only part of what they do.
They also have an API that
gets 40 to 50 billion API
calls a day from all
sorts of digital devices
and connected devices that
want to show you the weather.
But the interesting thing is
that their business is actually
much more than that.
There are businesses such
as insurance and financial
services, risk
management, reinsurance,
all kind of businesses like that
that the weather events have
a big impact on their business.
So Accuweather is able to sell
more valuable, basically more
expensive forecast products
tailored to those industries.
And the fact that if they
can have an API platform that
allows people to sign up and get
those products via self-service
by clicking a button on a
website, signing up for an API,
paying some money,
and using that API
they can get customers to
use those systems much more
quickly than they
might have in the past.
Last example I'll give
you is Ticketmaster.
In the United
States, Ticketmaster
is one of the companies
you go to buy tickets.
But an interesting stat
is that at least 10%
of the traffic of the
numbers of tickets that
are sold on Ticketmaster
are not sold directly
from Ticketmaster's website
or they're mobile app,
but from third parties.
For instance, there
are hotels who,
when you make your
hotel reservation
they say, hey, you'll be
in New York next week.
How about tickets to "Frozen?"
These kinds of things
actually happen using API.
And again it's a great example
of a company like Ticketmaster
using APIs to allow third
parties to drive new businesses
on top of their platform.
The reason why this
kind of thing can work
is that these companies treat
APIs not as a bit of technology
or about, hey, isn't it cool
that I can send you JSON
and get tickets to "Frozen."
But actually, that they think
about their APIs as products
that they sell to a customer.
They have to think about who
the customer is for their API.
So Magalu has to
think about if I'm
going to offer an API
for third party vendors
to sell stuff in my
network of stores
what kind of technologies
do those vendors have?
What are they going
to have to do in order
to actually get on my platform?
What can I do to
reduce the friction?
And how do I keep track
of that so it actually
affects my business.
Similarly, Accuweather
has to think about
if people are going to build
mobile apps or other kind
of digital experiences
on my services
what kind of technology
do I have to offer?
What kind of API do
you have to offer?
In other words,
these companies that
have done successful things
in their business with APIs
have done it because they
treat their APIs as products.
They have product managers,
the product managers
look at who the customer
segmentation is.
They look at analytics
and statistics
to see which APIs
our most popular.
And they introduce new APIs and
new API capabilities not based
on what would be cool
but based on what's
actually done by what actually
the numbers they're seeing.
They have a way of
becoming data driven.
And this is something
that any company that
does product management
knows how to do,
but a lot of companies that
are entering into the API world
from sort of an enterprise
integration perspective
aren't used to
thinking that way.
They're thinking about, I need
to solve a business problem.
I need to solve a
technology problem.
Wouldn't it be cool
if we could do this?
But the companies that
are successful with API
are thinking, we have
customers out there.
Our customers are
hotel chains who
want to build integrations with
Ticketmaster's ticketing API.
What kind of technology
platform do they have?
What features are
they looking for?
How do we engage
with those customers
and make it easy to sign up?
And these companies
essentially become--
they're in the same sort of
enterprise sales business
that Google Cloud is in
with managing relationships
with customers and treating
those APIs just the way
we treat any other product.
So that's about all I'm going
to say about the high level
of APIs and API management.
What we're now
going to do is Keith
is going to show us a
little bit about it.
What it looks like to
be a consumer of an API?
And if we could
switch to the demo.
Excellent.
Thank you.
KEITH DANEKIND: Thanks, Greg.
So we heard a little bit
about what these customers are
doing when they want
to produce APIs,
share them with the world.
What does it look
like when you want
to consume one of these APIs?
So let's imagine you're
an application developer
and you'd like to
write an application.
So I wanted to write an
application that would
look at historical weather.
I started thinking about weather
in different places and things
like that.
And I thought it would be nice
to be able to go back and look
at historical weather.
So the application I've
written here you can come in
and you can put in a location.
In this case, I've
typed in San Francisco.
When I hit this
find button up here
it will find weather stations
that are near that location.
And for each of those
I can select one
and then I can go back and
look at the weather history.
So I'm looking at San
Francisco downtown.
I've gone back to 1930.
And it's pulled down a
year of weather for me.
The red line is the
high temperature
in Fahrenheit, blue
line low temperature.
And January on the left,
and December on the right.
So nice application.
Very easy to write.
How did I do this?
So as an application developer,
really what I'm focused on
is the user experience.
And I just want the
data from somewhere
and I don't want to have to
go through a lot of trouble
to get it.
So I found this data
out on this web page.
So this is an example
of a developer portal.
What I'm seeing here is this
company's developer experience.
So as an application developer
I'm going to come out here
and I'm going to start reading
about what APIs are available,
what can I do with them
and things like that.
So as I come into here.
I'm going to look at--
looks like there's
some API products and some
things to get me started.
Looks like there's some sample
code in here that might help
me be able to use these things.
I'm going to come
down and look at--
let's try this Weather
History Try It Out--
provides 100 calls per
day for a developer.
Looks great.
So as I come into
here I'm going to find
that I've got a whole
list of APIs in here.
I've got one that will look
up particular weather stations
and I've got one that'll get me
temperature data or wind data.
The first one I want to try
is this weather station thing.
And they have a nice
little Try It Out over here
and some documentation.
So I would read through this.
And if we're thinking
like a developer
the goal is, OK, how do I
get data from this as quickly
as possible?
What kind of things
do I need to do?
How do I get authenticated?
How do I call this?
So for this it looks like
there is an API key required
and then we're going to provide
some sort of street address
or place.
So let's go up and register.
I'm already logged in here.
I'm going to register
an application
and that gives me an API key.
Let's call this Next Demo.
OK.
And we're going to go
with this Try It Out here.
And then I'm going to come
up here and hit Create.
And that's registered
my application.
So once my application
is registered
I've been given credentials
that I can try for this.
I've got a key and a secret.
I'm going to come
down here and I'm
going to cut and paste that key.
Next thing I want to do is I'm
going to go back to my APIs
and I'm going to try this out.
So now that I have my key.
Let's go into here.
And let's try San
Francisco again.
And that's going to pull down
some weather stations that
are near me.
GREG BRAIL: And it's a demo.
OK.
KEITH DANEKIND: There they are.
GREG BRAIL: OK.
Never mind.
KEITH DANEKIND: OK.
So I've got back a series
of weather stations.
So there's the
latitude and longitude
that matched San Francisco.
It went out to Google Maps,
it found that latitude
and longitude, brought
it back, and then
it's searching for
weather stations that
are near that point.
And it looks like
there's a few in there.
And there they are.
So I'm going to grab
this first one here.
And then we're going
to go over to here.
And it looks like we can
get temperature and wind
data for that particular
weather station.
So let's look up historical
temperature data.
I'm going to grab an API key.
And let's go back a few years.
Let's go back to,
let's say 1950.
And it's a demo.
[LAUGHS] OK.
We'll go back to our key.
Let's try this one.
GREG BRAIL: By the way, we
will be deleting all these APIs
keys when--
KEITH DANEKIND: Thanks, Greg.
GREG BRAIL: Because this
is going to be on YouTube.
KEITH DANEKIND: OK.
Now it works.
My API key is a little
bit stale there.
So I have got weather data back
for this particular weather
station that year.
And then there's a whole array
of 365 days of weather data.
So that was pretty easy to do.
I could take that and I could
build an application from it.
GREG BRAIL: So now we've
impersonated an API consumer.
KEITH DANEKIND: Yes.
GREG BRAIL: Now
we're going to go
behind the curtains a little bit
and impersonate an API product
manager.
KEITH DANEKIND: Yes.
GREG BRAIL: Basically,
how would you,
as a company that wants
to offer such an API,
make the sign on experience
for your customers
as easy as what
Keith just showed?
And how do you
actually, as a product
manager-- what do you do?
How do you actually keep
track of who's using your API?
KEITH DANEKIND: Right.
So I've configured
some things in here
to productize these APIs.
I want to think about--
I've got a set of
services, but how
do I turn those into a
package that I can share?
I have different people
who want to consume them
and I might want to
package them different ways
because different people have
different rights to these.
Let's imagine I've got a bunch
of partners, some of them
are allowed to do
some things, others
are allowed to do other things.
And I want to control how
frequently they can call this.
I want to place some rate limits
on them and things like that.
So I've packaged these
up into these products
that we see here.
What I'm really concerned
about daily though is,
what do the analytics look like?
Who's calling them?
What are they doing?
How can I improve
my API program?
So for that, I'm
going to come in
and we're going to look at a
few different reports in here.
So I'm now playing the
role of an API manager.
And what I might do on
a daily basis is come in
and look at some
of these reports.
So what I'm seeing here
is my proxy performance.
And I can see traffic
rolling into here
and I get an idea of the
most basic metric here.
How many people are calling this
thing and what are they doing?
So there's traffic,
average response time,
traffic by proxy, average
response time by proxy.
Another thing I might be
interested in is looking at--
Let me restart these
so my demo's better.
OK.
Another the thing I
might want to look at
is developer engagement.
And that's going to show
me who's called here?
So how many people have called
this, what have they done,
and that sort of thing?
Let's jump ahead to
one that's loaded.
So another thing that's
really important.
Let's look at devices.
So I want to know who's on
iOS, who's on Windows, who's
on Android, that sort of thing.
This might influence how I'm
going to build my mobile apps
and things like that.
So this report is going to
show me who's coming in,
and what they're doing, and how
much traffic I have by device.
I may come in and
want to look at a map.
And the map would show me where
all my traffic is coming from.
And I can zoom in and I can
look at a particular location
and get an idea of who's
calling from where.
So I've got some traffic
coming from California.
Not unexpected.
But I can get an
idea of where people
are calling from the latency
from those different locations
and things like that.
I might want to create
a custom report.
And in this custom
report, I'm going
to look at traffic
by weather station.
So maybe I have a
curiosity just to know
where are people searching
for these weather stations.
Which ones are interesting
and what are they pulling up?
So there's a number of metrics
that are provided for me.
And I've also collected
a custom metric
that I grabbed out
of the request,
and that was the
particular weather
stations they're looking for.
And that's what's
shown in this report.
So that's a quick tour of what
I might do as an API product
manager when I look through
all these different analytics.
GREG BRAIL: Cool.
Thanks.
We can go back to
the slides now.
We've talked a
little bit about what
it would look like to be
the consumer of an API.
Basically, what we
saw was, gee, it
was really easy to
sign up to get a key
to get credentials and
start calling that API.
We also looked a
little bit at what
it would look like to be
an API product manager.
If I'm an API product
manager what do I do?
How do I actually manage the
people who were using API?
And that's really important
because the companies
that have succeeded with APIs
have treated them as products.
And really taken that product
management discipline to heart.
We're going to get back to
some of the technology later.
But we're going to
move on a little bit,
and we're going to talk
a little bit about some
of the high level
technologies you
need to understand in order to
run a successful API program.
What are some
specific things that
make APIs and API management
a different kind of technology
than other things
that are out there?
Well, the first
thing is what I've
been calling a lot API
consumer management,
but it's really API management.
API management is
a set of technology
that manages the relationship
between the consumer's
of an API and the
producers of an API.
And it's really the only bit
of technology in the enterprise
that does that.
It's extremely important
for these kinds of use cases
we've been talking about.
Because it's the only way
for an API product manager
to understand who
is using their API,
how much are they
using their API.
And allows them
to create products
that actually comprise
the APIs that allow you
to have different offerings.
So in Keith's demo, there
was a free developer version
of the weather app that you
could call 100 times a day.
And presumably, if we
had clicked father maybe
if he wanted to launch
an app on the app store
and have 100 million API
calls a day on that same API,
he would probably have
some way on that form
to speak to the
API product manager
directly and negotiate terms of
service or prices or whatever.
Sophisticated
companies and companies
that have large numbers of
APIs inside their companies
use the API management
product not only
to manage relationships
with external partners
but also internally.
If you want to be
able to, say, offer
an API within a large
financial services organization
and let anybody in the
organization use your API,
you need a way for them to
sign up, get credentials.
You may have APIs that you
want to make visible only
to certain teams.
You may eventually want to make
those APIs visible externally
and you may have certain
partners who have access
to certain API and certain
partners that don't.
Many companies that
have been running
APIs for many
years in production
need these kind of capabilities
and rather than build
a lot of these things
ad hoc and from scratch
as some companies do, API
management products actually
exist that basically give you
a way to manage all this stuff.
So really when I talk about
APIs and API management,
I spend a lot of time on
this because to me, this
is what API management is.
It's technology to manage that
relationship between producers
and consumers.
But there are other
parts to API management
as well that are really
important in that in order
to run a successful API,
it's important to understand.
One of them is OAuth.
OAuth as the de facto
standard for access control
for mobile
applications and really
any kind of applications.
And it's even used for your
single sign on via web apps.
If you're using an app
that uses a Google API,
you're using OAuth.
If you're using a website
that uses these APIs,
or if you're signing into
Twitter, or if you're at work
and you clicked on your
internal link that signs you
into your health
insurance account
and the web browser redirects
47 times, that's also OAuth.
OAuth has become this
de facto standard
and also it's a set
of IETF standards,
because it makes possible to
decouple the different parts
of the identity relationship.
It allows the API
gateway, which is usually
a proxy that's sitting
in between the clients
and the back ends, to
actually look at access tokens
and decide whether an API call
should be accepted or rejected.
And it allows that API
gateway to be separate
from the identity system that
actually signs in the user.
So that's why when
you see websites
that have Sign In via
Google, Sign In via Facebook,
or Sign In via GitHub all
of that is done using OAuth.
And people build open APIs
and mobile applications
using that same technology.
And an interesting
thing about OAuth
is that each OAuth
token, which is the thing
that your mobile
device actually sends
when it makes an API
call to identify you,
not only is unique.
So it would tell you it
identifies a certain device,
it identifies the
user who signed
in using the IDP in
order to get the token.
But it also identifies
the application
that made the request.
So the reason why OAuth is so
important to API management
is going back to
this slide here.
Because each OAuth token
identifies the consumer
of the API exactly what
application built the API.
This can be really important.
We've seen cases for instance,
where a customer launches
an API and they have a
problem in production
because a new version
of a client application
has gone out of control
for any kind of numbers
and is sending thousands of
requests a second to the API
from phones all over the world.
Well, without
understanding exactly
which application is
making that request
there's not much
you can do about it.
But if you have an API
management system in,
or it's wire it
up to your OAuth,
you might be able to say,
take all the requests
from this application and black
hole them to another server.
Or even reject them entirely
at the API gateway layer
so they don't bring down the
rest of my infrastructure.
Two other really important
bits of API management.
One of them are quotas.
Quotas are something we
see in every API today.
Those of you who are
Google Cloud customers,
and we hope you will all
be Google Cloud customers,
are probably frustrated with
the fact that quotas exist.
But they're essential for any
company that offers a platform.
Google has quotas
on its Cloud APIs
to prevent for instance, someone
putting their credentials
in GitHub and getting
picked up there and used
to spin the 100,000 virtual
machines for Bitcoin mining.
I would say that never happens,
but it totally happens.
Similarly, we have
quotas to protect us
against those sorts of things.
Anyone who has an API in
production you need quotas
if you're going to
let people sign up
for your API for self-service.
Why do you want to do that?
You want to do that
because that's self-service
that we saw, any developer
can click a button
and use an API
within five minutes,
it only works if
you have some way
to control the amount of
traffic coming into your API
so that a new user doesn't
overwhelm your capacity.
And you can't do that
unless you have a quota
and unless you have an
API management system that
can let you control which
application is using your API
and by how much.
Good quota systems let you
set all kinds of quotas
and also let you do
things like reset
them, have different
levels of service
for different customers,
and change them.
So for instance, if you actually
do need 100,000 VMs on Google
Cloud, there is a way that
you can ask a Google support
person to increase your
quota because now we
know who you are, we trust
you, and we know you're not
doing bitcoin mining.
So these are the
kinds of things that
become really important
when you run API at scale.
Security threats are
a big deal of course.
OAuth is a big part of
security but API gateways
are very important
for security but they
operate at the highest level.
They're able to tell
you if an API call has
a legitimate access
token or it comes
from a legitimate application.
But there are other kinds
of security threats as well.
For instance, let's
imagine that Keith
had amended his API to let you
send in using some sort of JSON
payload what the weather is now.
Hey, you know, it's actually
raining in San Francisco.
Your app told me it was sunny.
Well, a whole lot of things
could go wrong with that.
Right?
To start with, the
description of the weather
might not be something
that they want to publish
but that's a different problem.
But yeah, you're accepting
JSON from untrusted people
on the internet.
So what's to stop someone from
sending you a 100 megabyte
comment.
Not that JSON has comments,
but a 100 megabyte string
or something that's less
than 10,000 levels deep.
Or instead of your
weather station ID
they put in semicolon
delete star from customers
or something like that.
All of these kinds
of threats are real
and can happen when you're
accepting data like JSON or XML
or something else from
an untrusted party.
And it's really
important to be able
protect against those things.
So a lot of APIs gateways
can do that as well.
I'll also mention DDoS.
A lot of people say, Oh, I need
an API gateway they protect me
from DDoS attacks.
The truth is that API
gateway technology
is essential for these kinds
of things because of quotas,
because of
authentication, but that's
got to be a fully
multi-layered approach.
So that's why we have
DDoS protection built
into Google Cloud.
We have additional products like
Cloud Armor that give you more
sophisticated DDoS protection.
But there are many layers
necessary in any kind
of internet facing products
to protect against those.
Finally, I'll mention one
part of API management
that's not really as tightly
connected to the others
but it's something
that becomes very
important in the
real world, which
is mediation and
transformation and integration.
Many of the examples I
used at the beginning
of this presentation
were companies
that created new
digital experiences
on top of legacy systems.
Because almost everybody
out there in the world
has legacy systems.
Well, those legacy
systems usually
don't present the kind of API
that for instance, the Google
Home device expects or
that a mobile application
developer is using.
They may return
you know 25k of XML
when what a mobile app really
needs is 200 bytes and JSON.
They may not have been
designed for the internet era
and may not even
contemplate being
used by hundreds of thousands
or millions of people.
Their response time may be low.
So it can be very,
very important
to be able to use something
like an API gateway
to mediate and transform
different technologies
so you can take that
SOAP application that's
been in production for 15
years, build an API on it,
and then be able
to use it to launch
a new digital experience.
This even goes sort of
in the forward direction.
Developers who are building
things with microservices today
love to use
technology like gRPC.
It's efficient, it's
easily integrated
with certain
programming languages.
It is easier to develop
depending on the context.
But often, if you're
doing something
like talking to a
mobile app you want
to transform that into something
like JSON over HTTP, which
is something that all
developers can understand
and an increasing number of
APIs gateways do that as well.
So let me take a
few minutes here
and talk about our products.
Because so far, if I'm talking
about API Management, API
Management companies who
actually do APIs, and what
it can do in particular,
sorry, in a generic way,
let me talk about what we
have to offer at Google.
Google actually
offers two products
in the world of API management.
These are both actually
owned by the same team
and I'm responsible for the
architecture of both of them.
Cloud Endpoints has been a part
of Google Cloud for a while.
The advantage of
Cloud Endpoints is
that it is a very
small, simple, fast,
easy to set up
product that gives you
the basics of API management.
You can verify an API
key, you can set a quota.
You can do some
basic authentication.
A lot of companies use
Cloud Endpoints in order
to build digital experiences
in front of workloads that
already run on Google Cloud.
It takes advantage of many
of the API capabilities
that are built into Google
Cloud, such as the quotas
and authentication you're
already using if you're
a Google Cloud customer.
The other product
we have is Apigee.
Apigee was acquired by
Google in the late 2016.
It's what I've primarily been
working on for the last third
of my career.
And then Apigee does
basically everything
around API management.
Not only running as
a basic API Gateway
to do things like
authentication,
but also there's things like a
customizable developer portal,
a highly sophisticated and
customizable quota mechanism,
caching, API monitoring,
customizable API analytics,
monetization.
So if you choose to
charge money for an API
you can use Apigee to assign a
value to particular API calls
and then generate a bill
for customers later.
And many companies,
especially larger enterprises
that have a lot of these
enterprise complexities to them
find that they need the
sophistication of an API
management product
like Apigee in order
to really solve their problems.
So the ones who were
saying, hey, you
know the foreign exchange
department shouldn't
be able to call the equity
trading departments APIs
unless it's approved by a VP.
These are the kinds of things
that happen in the real world
and they make API management
more than just checking
an API key in a Redis
table but actually
doing some more sophisticated
roles based access controls.
These are the kinds of things
that a lot of customers
use Apigee to do.
It's important to mention
that Apigee actually
runs in multiple modes.
One of them is
software as a service.
Everything runs by Google in the
cloud in all of Google's data
centers.
Other end of the
spectrum is on premise.
You can take the whole thing and
put it in your own data center
and not touch the
internet at all.
There's a number of companies
who have historically
had to do that for a
whole number of reasons.
What we're seeing now
even more and more
people need to be able
to run in multi cloud
and in a hybrid environment.
And obviously, you heard a lot
about that at the conference
already today.
So Apigee also has a hybrid
mode where the API gateway that
actually sits in between the
client and server of the API
traffic can run on your own
data center, or your own cloud,
or really anywhere
you want it to be.
While some of the other
parts of Apigee like,
the management
and the analytics,
can run as a service run by us.
And with that said,
Keith is now going
to show us how to actually
build the APIs that he showed
and apply the API
management capabilities he
showed using Apigee.
And sorry, can we
go to the demo?
There we go.
KEITH DANEKIND: So we talked
about how people consume this.
But what did it take
to build this service?
So we saw that we have this
nice weather application
with all this data on here.
Where's the data coming
from and what's behind this?
So let me talk about how
I built that using Apigee.
So what we have in here
is on the left hand side
there you see a
client application
and it uses API keys to
talk to the back end system.
The data is out in BigQuery and
I've got one of the public data
sets out there is
historical weather
and it has weather going
back a few hundred years.
And I thought it'd be
kind of cool to use that.
But the challenges
I ran into was
I need to authenticate
with Google Cloud
and to do that I have to
go get an access token.
There's some credentials that
need to be exchanged in there
and I need to send a
header to the back end.
So that process isn't
really important to who
is consuming this.
On the consumption
side of this I
wanted to have API keys
so I could identify
different applications.
I could on board
people pretty quickly.
So what we're seeing in here
is the left side of this
is one set of security,
the right side
is a different set of security.
I also had some other
concerns in there.
Some of the things
that Greg mentioned.
we worry about
as we start to share
data with new people.
And those are things
like, how do we build
a facade on this back end?
So I want to take
everything that's
back there no matter
when it was written
and make it look clean and
new to the consumers of this.
So I want to change the
requests and responses that are
coming back and forth in there.
I wanted to control
access to some features.
So you can try it out for free
and you can get 100 calls.
If you're a valued partner
maybe you can come in
and you can look at
more things if you
have a different
relationship with us.
I wanted to rate limit
to protect the back.
So we need to have
things in there
so that if your application
has a loop in there that's
uncontrolled, we
don't want to melt
the back end for everybody.
We want to shut you down.
So rate limiting.
And I want to impose some
quotas for business reasons.
I want to have different tiers
of service for different people
so that I could
charge accordingly.
And I want to add
caching in here.
So if somebody makes the
same request twice let's
just call it from
memory and let's not
go all the way to the back end.
And reformat the
request in the response.
So that's what I built. That's
what this diagram represents.
Let's look at
what's behind this.
So how did I get there?
So the next role
for me to play here
as the demo person
is we're going
to look at what does it
take to build and manage
a service that you want
to expose to other people.
So I started off
with a specification
and I thought about, I
know what's in the database
and know how that's
formatted, but what
do I want to present
to the outside world?
And for that I wrote this
spec an OpenAPI spec.
I did this in Apigee.
I've come in here
and I've described
what the endpoints are.
I've described the data
formats and things like that.
I did that in this
left hand pane.
On the right hand
side here I can
see a rendering of what my
documentation will look like.
So that was the documentation
we saw on the website.
This is what guided the
developers on how to use it.
The next thing I did
was I took that spec
and I turned it into
an API proxy in Apigee.
And what this does
is this is going
to control that
request and response
flow that goes back and forth.
What we see in here
is there's a URL
appear I'm going to start
calling Inside of Apigee.
And that's going to call this
BigQuery API on the back end.
If I click over here on Develop
what I'm going to see in here
is a graphical depiction of
the request and response flow.
So what we're seeing is this
is the request coming in
on the top, right
up here, and then we
see the response coming
back on the bottom.
And I going to do a few
things along the way
to manage this request
and response flow.
For example, I'm
going to come in
and I will do some
rate limiting.
And right down here,
I'm going to limit them
to 10 calls per minute.
That's not very fast
but it's something
I can demonstrate
breaking in a demo.
So these different policies
are run on the request side.
These policies are run
on the response side.
I have different flows in here
that can do different things.
I've got a whole set
of policies over here
that when I click that plus
button they'll get added.
Things for traffic management.
How do we control just the
basic flow going back and forth
in there?
Things for security.
As we start to share
with new people
were always concerned
about security.
So basic auth to check for
user names and passwords.
OAuth, as Greg mentioned, to
tie into our identity management
system and to identify
who's calling.
I might want to reformat things.
I might want to turn
my JSON and XML,
XML to JSON if I've got a
legacy system on the back end.
I may want to extend this with
Java call outs, Python call
outs, or JavaScript.
Or I might want
to take advantage
of certain things
in Google Cloud
by using some of these
extensions that are specific.
So those are all different
policies I might add in there.
That manages my request
and my response flow.
And then depending on how
this is called, depending
on what people put at
the end of the URL,
I might want to do
different things.
So looking for a weather station
I might execute these things.
First thing I'm
going to do in there
is look up an API key that's
going to give me access
to Google Maps.
And I'm going to use that to
make a call out and look up
that city.
So when I type in San Francisco,
what I'm really looking for
is the latitude and
longitude of San Francisco
because that's how the weather
stations are in my database.
I'm going to look at
the response of that.
I'm going to grab the latitude
and longitude out of that.
I'm going to draw nice little
box around that with some code
and figure out an
area where I want
to search for weather stations.
That's right there.
And then finally, I'm going
to build up a BigQuery request
and I'm going to
completely replace
this request with a whole
new body and send that in.
And this is completely
hidden from my consumer.
When I get the
response back, I'm
going to format the
response that comes back
to make it look more
pleasing and more
useful to my developer.
So those are all
different things
that I would do in
here to build this up.
So I'm going to
send in requests,
I'm going to see responses.
Now, along the way,
it's remotely possible
that I made a mistake in my
code and I need to debug this.
So I'm going to come in and
I'm going to show what it looks
like to debug in here.
What I've done is I've
turned on Trace in here
and this is going to let me look
at detailed request response
flow in here.
So I'll come back over to my
weather application and we'll
go back to--
let's go back just to 2015--
and we'll send a
request in there
to look up temperature data
and I'll send in a few.
And this should shut
me down after a bit
because I'm being rate limited.
So if it come back over to
here we'll see those rolling in
and we can see a detailed
response of exactly
what happened in there.
So here's the request coming in.
We can see all the
details of what
was received by the client.
We can see API keys
being processed,
metadata being loaded to
describe who the person is.
We see our rate limit
in here coming in.
You'll notice over here
that we see a 429 error.
We've applied rate limiting
because this person was
calling too quickly.
So what they're going
to see in that case
is they're going to see
a nice error that says,
Call rate exceeded-- this
application is limited
to 10 requests per minute.
So instead of seeing that big
500 something horrible happened
and we don't know
what it is, you're
going to see a
helpful error that's
going to help you
debug your application.
So that's what I
did to build this.
This was easy for me.
I had a back end system.
I made a few calls
to it, I figured out
what the format was.
I thought about how do
I want to manage that.
I went into Apigee and
here I built an API proxy
and then that's how people
are going to call this.
So that's a quick example of how
you build something in Apigee
and exactly what the
steps are to do that.
GREG BRAIL: Cool.
So in the beginning,
we showed you
what it might look like to
be the consumer of an API
then we talked a
little about what
it would look like to be
an API product manager.
And now Keith is
showing us what does
it look like to actually
use Apigee to create
the policies in order to
make the API work the way
that I want it to.
Now, if we could go back
to the slides for a sec?
Something we didn't mention at
the beginning, which is that we
have this really nifty way--
not that way, that way--
of having you ask questions.
This is an internal
Google tool using
at Next for the first time.
It's called Dory.
I think after the
character in the show.
But anyway, and I see that we
didn't tell you about this,
because no one has
asked any questions.
So this is a great
way to ask questions
because it lets you type in your
question on your mobile device
by going to the link
that's in the Next app
for this particular session.
And the cool thing about it
is that if your neighbors ask
tedious questions you
can vote them down.
Or if they ask really good
questions you can vote them up.
So we have only a
few more minutes
till the session is over.
But we will also look
when the session is
over at what
questions are on there
and we'll answer them online
if people ask them later.
I wanted to mention two more
things before we were done.
One of them is that we actually
do-- and this is not a product
announcement session,
but we actually
have announced a couple
of products today.
I mentioned hybrid
earlier for Apigee.
Hybrid is a way that you
can take the API gateway
part of Apigee, which is
what Keith was just demoing,
and run that anywhere you want,
including your own data center
while the rest of Apigee such
as the API analytics, the API
product management,
and all those kinds
of things including some
of the user interface
runs in Google's Cloud.
This is something our
customers have been asking us
for a long time because
many, many customers
even if they are
completely bought
into cloud computing
many of them
still have, and may have
for a long time to come,
stuff that runs in
their own data centers
or even in other clouds
or in private clouds.
So Apigee hybrid gives
you a way to do this.
That is in beta starting today.
We also have something called
API security reporting,
which is based on some of the
analytics that Keith showed.
It gives you a little
bit more details
about how your API
traffic is behaving
and it alerts you to things
like anomalous API traffic.
Or even mistakes you might have
made like not configuring TLS
properly for your APIs.
And finally, some of the
policies that Keith showed in
that policy editor
are actually things
that you can extend
yourself using a capability
called Apigee extensions.
There are pre-built extensions
for many popular integration
technologies like SAP, like
many of the Google Cloud APIs.
And yes, also many of the
Amazon APIs because many of you
use Amazon APIs as well.
Apigee extensions
is fully GA now
it's been part of the Apigee
product for a little while.
Last thing I'm going to mention
before we go to questions
is that we have a
whole lot of sessions
related to APIs and API
management here at Cloud.
This session will be videotaped
I can't give you the slides.
But it will be on YouTube.
It won't be videotaped,
it will be recorded
and it'll be on YouTube.
It will be recorded on
an 8 millimeter film.
But if you want to take
a picture of this a lot
of the companies that I
mentioned who are actually
doing things with APIs such
as Accuweather and Magalu
are going to be
presenting here at Next.
WooliesX is sort of
the experimental arm
of Woolworth's in Australia.
They do a lot with APIs
in digital technology.
As does Kaiser Permanente,
Equifax, HP, and Urban Science.
So I apologize for any of
the sessions being full
but it does seem like
if you are patient
you can get in after the
first 10 or 15 minutes.
So if you're looking to
learn more about APIs and API
management then that's
a great thing to do.
KEITH DANEKIND: I've
got a few questions
on the Dory here I can take.
GREG BRAIL: Yeah.
Well, we're not
going to present them
because we don't want
to out people's names
but we're going to start.
And Yeah, well, let's answer
a few of the questions.
KEITH DANEKIND: The
first question here.
How do you manage API versions?
So this one comes up
almost every time I
demoed this product.
So there's two concepts here.
One, is basic revisions
in the API proxy.
So let's say add
caching but I'm not
changing the contract of how
this calls back and forth.
There is a built in revisioning
system within Apigee
to manage the
revisions of those API
proxies you saw me manipulating.
The other thing is versioning.
Let's say I break
that contract and I'm
going to change the format
that comes back completely.
There are many ways to do this.
Apigee supports all
kinds of ways to do this.
The most common we're
seeing is that people
will put V1 or V2
or V3 in the URL
as far to the left as possible.
And you can deploy
this API proxy,
you can make a copy of
it and deploy a new one
and call that version 2 and
it can behave differently.
You can tie the
analytics to that
so you can measure who's on
version 1, who's on version 2.
Much better than
the old way which
is just to turn off one
and see who gets angry.
So this is better.
GREG BRAIL: And you
can also find out
who is using that old
version of the API so--
KEITH DANEKIND: Yes.
GREG BRAIL: --you can maybe
even send them an email and say,
what's going on?
KEITH DANEKIND:
Or slow them down.
GREG BRAIL: [LAUGHS]
Or slow them--
KEITH DANEKIND: Give
them A little motivation.
GREG BRAIL: You
could do that, yes.
KEITH DANEKIND: So that's how
we would do versioning in here.
And you can keep
iterating on there,
you can measure it,
and do it formally.
So nice feature of that.
Let me see what else is in here.
GREG BRAIL: Someone
asked about open API 3.
I actually thought
that we either
did that we're about to do it.
KEITH DANEKIND: It
is on the roadmap.
I don't know if we
can give details
since they record
us and everything,
but it's on the roadmap.
GREG BRAIL: OK.
Let's see.
Why would anyone
use Cloud Endpoints?
I really should be I'll
answer the question by now.
One of the advantage
about endpoints
is it's very simple to
get started with it's also
very inexpensive.
So it does a few things,
but it does them well,
and it does them
at a very low cost.
This can be very
important if you
have-- because what we see
for instance, is companies
have very sophisticated API
programs with lots of bells
and whistles and complex
transformations and things,
but that may be for
a low volume things.
For a consumer
application that's
called hundreds of millions
or billions of times a day,
sometimes you may only need
a basic quota and an API
key check.
And Cloud Endpoints can do that.
And it can do that
at a low price point.
And we're actually continuing
to develop Cloud Endpoints.
We're going to see
actually, over the next year
or two some more
enhancements to it.
And over time Cloud
Endpoints and Apigee
will be happy together.
Sorry, my app crashed.
OK.
Is there are another
one you want to take?
KEITH DANEKIND:
I see another one
in here asking about
GraphQL API support.
So this is coming up
more and more where
people are asking about this.
You can send anything that's
HTTP back and forth in here.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be REST.
So people use this with SOAP.
I've seen people use it with
OData and other protocols
they're going to
add on top of that.
We're looking at how
to support GraphQL.
We don't have anything
in there today
but it is something we're
definitely looking at.
But feel free to use
it with GraphQL today.
You will find value
in that and we've
seen a few patterns on how to
support it well with Apigee.
GREG BRAIL: Right.
Can all of this be
configured via framework
such as Serverless or arc.codes?
I don't know what arc.codes is.
I don't think Serverless
is working with Apigee yet.
But we've had people
talk about it.
Everything in Apigee
however, is done via API.
KEITH DANEKIND: Yeah.
GREG BRAIL: So what many people
have done-- so for instance,
you showed doing things with
a GUI but when most people do
is there's a Maven plug-in and
an AMP plug-- well, maybe not.
Nobody uses AMP anymore.
There's a Jenkins plug-in.
A lot of people have prebuilt
integrations with the APIs
to automate the process of
defining APIs and pushing them
out.
And that's an example of
how you might do that.
KEITH DANEKIND: Everything
that is in the UI is also
supported through API.
So our UI is built
on top of those APIs.
So you can also use
those to automate that
and a lot of people will
tie that into their CI/CD.
GREG BRAIL: Yeah.
How do I get on board
the Apigee hybrid beta?
We should have a [INAUDIBLE].
KEITH DANEKIND: Come talk to
us in the hallway afterwards
and I'll give you
an answer that.
GREG BRAIL: Let's see.
Can Apigee be used to manage
a large inventory of APIs
with thousands of internal
users versus external users.
We've definitely
had people do that.
KEITH DANEKIND: We've had
a lot of people do that.
GREG BRAIL: We have customers
who have hundreds of thousands
of consumers of their APIs.
KEITH DANEKIND: Does Apigee
have a circuit breaker
for services that slow down?
It certainly does.
We've got a spike
arrest policy in there.
That can be inserted in
there so that if it's
called too frequently it
will shut them down and use
the circuit breaker pattern.
GREG BRAIL: Right.
Someone asked about
using Apigee as a proxy
between internal microservices
as well as publishing them.
There are actually a
couple ways to do that.
There is a version of
the API gateway called
the micro gateway,
which people sometimes
co-located with lots of services
so that they can run it.
They can have lots of
little API gateways instead
of a few big ones.
Also, there is integration
between Apigee and Istio.
So if you're running
an Istio service mesh--
and if there's no one
at this conference
running Istio or service
mesh, we would definitely
have them here.
You can actually plug
Apigee into the Istio Mixer
so that once Istio is managing
your services in the mesh,
you can use Apigee for quota
for API key verification.
And we're making some
progress on OAuth as well.
The use case for that
is I have a number
of services running in Istio--
and Istio, by the way as a
part of the new cloud services
platform that has a name
that I've already forgotten.
I'm sorry.
But anyway, Apigee.
Istio is part of that.
If you have Istio and you have
services in the Istio mesh
let's imagine you want to turn
one or two of those services
into APIs, publish them to
users outside that service mesh,
and use the developer portals or
quotas API keys and OAuth stuff
that we showed you
in the demos today.
You can do that
in Istio right now
by integrating Istio with Apigee
whether Apigee is on premise,
hybrid, or in the cloud.
KEITH DANEKIND: We're
running low on time.
I'll take one more
question from the Dory here
and then I think we'll wrap up.
So one of you is asking, how do
you get free access to Apigee?
So go to apigee.com
in the upper right,
you'll see a nice free trial.
You can click on that button
and sign up for a trial account
and you can try out
and build things.
GREG BRAIL: So we're
going to wrap it up now.
The next session
starts very soon.
We can hang around
outside for questions.
There's also an Apigee
booth in the expo area
where there are a
lot of people there
who are experts who
can talk to you.
We'd be happy to
talk more to you
and then we'll get back on a few
of the Dory questions as well.
KEITH DANEKIND: Thank you.
GREG BRAIL: So thanks
you for coming.
Enjoy your next sessions.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]